Ja dass er hinter mir das ist atlas der größte
teilchendetektor der welt im größten teilchenbeschleuniger der welt der large hadron collider kurz lhc
am cern in genf das ist übrigens auch die größte
forschungsanlage der welt aber es geht noch mehr und so startet jetzt die aufrüstung der anlage
statt einer milliarde
protonen kollisionen pro sekunde soll der beschleuniger schon bald fünf milliarden
schaffen wie der ausbau des lhc genau vonstatten geht und was das ganze mit außerirdischen zu tun hat jetzt den klicks und science fiction
direkt vom lhc aus dem cern hierbei games herzlich willkommen
Ja bislang ist der ringförmige tunnel hier 100 meter unter der erde also unter diesem
gebäude ganze 27 kilometer lang doch die europäische organisation für kernforschung cern
rückt jetzt mit baggern und bohrmaschinen allerdings unterirdisch neue tunnel stücke werden angebaut werden
leistungsstärkere magnete ein gesetz kommen wir uns gleich an steht hier einer direkt um die ecke und insgesamt sollen
auch mehr protonen kollidieren daher auch der name des
lhc projekt in das eine milliarde euro investiert werden denn wenn mehr protonen kollidieren wird es in der anlage auch stärker leuchten
daher der begriff hai lu - it I was so viel heißt wie hohe leistungsfähigkeit
leuchtkraft etwa 130 neue magnete werden dafür benötigt darunter 24
supraleitende quattropole die den strahl fokussieren hier liegt bereits eine also nicht ganz klein diese dinger mehr als 1,2 km
der aktuellen anlage werden umgebaut und optimiert
zudem sollen die maschinen besser für wartungsarbeiten
zugänglich gemacht werden und außerdem auch effizienter werden dazu der projektleiter oliver brüning es ist wie bei einer hausrenovierung
man baut eine neue heizung ein
die effizienter ist aber um mehr zu heizen braucht man mehr holz und entsprechend größere keller
so ganz stimmt dieser vergleich dann aber doch nicht denn die pläne des cern sind
gewaltig und so muss so manches material das verbaut werden soll erst einmal entwickelt werden so werden beispielsweise
kabel gebraucht die die deutlich stärkeren magnetfelder
überhaupt außerhalb zudem werden auch neuartige kabel aus magnesium die porit entwickelt die für den stromtransport von den steckdosen zu den magneten
einsetzbar sind dadurch dass das material eine
supraleitende verbindung ist wird der energieverbrauch für den betrieb der magnete gesenkt eine entwicklung die auch für den einsatz in der industrie
interessant sein könnte bei den experimenten des large hadron collider kurz lhc geht es hauptsächlich um
protonen kollisionen
die
forschungsteams erhoffen sich durch den ausbau der anlage bislang unbekannte
elementarteilchen auf die schliche zu kommen seltene phänomene zu untersuchen und genauere messungen durchzuführen
kriegt will man sich weiter mit dem higgs-boson
beschaffen dass 2012 ja hier entdeckt wurde das upgrade des lhc soll es dann schon bald
erlauben seine eigenschaft näher zu definieren das higgs boson
kurz das ist ja für die masse von materie warum zuständig und zudem sehr genau
wollen sie es messe wie es entsteht zerfällt und auch mit anderen teilchen
interagiert konkret will das cern die anzahl der kollision pro sekunde um von einer milliarde auf mindestens 5 milliarden erhöhen
dafür sollen nicht nur soll nicht nur mehr protonen zirkulieren sondern der
zusammenstoß auf 8 statt 16 mikrometer fokussiert werden dazu der cern generaldirektor
fabiola gianotti
der ausgebaute lhc wird die ursprüngliche mission erweitern und die eigenschaften von teilchen wie dem higgs boson mit grösserer präzision
messen und die fundamentalen bestandteile des universums
immer tiefer erforschen der aufbau der anlage
kommt gerade recht denn wenn man es genau nimmt und auf den punkt bringt läuft der physik die zeit davon auch wenn das sogenannte
standardmodell der letzten jahre immer weiter perfektioniert wurde ist allen klar
dass es dringend überarbeitet werden muss denn bestimmte formen von energie und materie wie etwa die dunkle materie und die dunkle energie
passen einfach nicht in dieses modell doch sie existieren davon sind zumindest die meisten forscher und forscherinnen immer noch
überzeugt und denn sonst könnte das universum nicht expandieren und galaxien würden sich in den
außenbereichen ganz viel langsamer drehen doch genau das passiert eben gar us ihn drehen sie schnell das universum
expandiert und so könnte der optimierte lhc dabei helfen nach den fehlern in der theorie zu suchen und im besten fall eine richtung vorzugeben
dies dann mit der physik weitergehen könnte oder eben vielleicht beides zu widerlegen so oder so wird es wahrscheinlich
bahnbrechende entdeckungen geben die bauarbeiten wurden zunächst oberirdisch gestartet mitte juni wurde dann mit den ersten
arbeiten begonnen vor allem an zwei
hauptstandort nämlich in der schweiz und in frankreich sind umfangreiche tiefbauarbeiten
notwendig weil der lhc der geht hier durch zwei länder hier entstehen neue gebäude neue schächte unterirdische hallen und
verschiedene anlagen für kühlung lüftung und elektrizität der plan sieht vor dass der beschleuniger ab
2025 als super beschleuniger durchstarten kann mit allen neuen messinstrumenten magneten und kabeln es bleibt also spannend
und wird noch spannender und ein wirklich spannender fact am rande gestern abend habe ich mich lange mit einem mitglied des staats
haben atlas detektor
unterhalten was diese anlage mit außerirdischen zu tun hat es ist so ziemlich die einzige maschine die eine intelligente
spezies
bauen muss um sich weiter zu entwickeln wenn es also stimmt dass es wahrscheinlich sehr viele solcher
zivilisationen gibt dann muss es diese maschine unzählige male im weltall geben vielleicht ist sehr eine spur zu
außerirdischen
zivilisationen wenn er keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die
kaputte abo box hier auf youtube und verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich um garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks ohne social media abonnieren
deshalb da gibt es immer das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken und nicht natürlich nicht die
leute vergessen genau und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
herkunft der geister teilchen enträtselt bis dann
bleibt dran